نبقى مشاهدينا في ايران ايضا نهج سكاد
الافواه وايضا قطع الانترنت لعدم وصول ما
يجري في الشارع للخارج هو تكتيك متبع على
مدى سنوات في ايران اليوم هناك خطه مدروسه
من المتوقع ان يصادق البرلمان عليها وتهدف
الى تجريم تصوير الاحداث ونشرها على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي جمعيه الصحفيين في
طهران حذرت من خطه المتابعه القانونيه
والقضائيه للاخبار الكاذبه في الفضاء
السيبراني ومشروع قانون في الحكومه وذلك
بعنوان قانون الصحافه الشامل بمعنى ان اي
تصوير لمسرح الجرائم او نشر او اعاده نشر
لقطات او صور مسجله تم اعدادها بشكل غير
ملخص سيعاد بهذا الاطار جريمه يحكم على
مرتكبها بالسجن وذلك من الدرجه الخامسه
الخطه وضعت باخانه تجريم العمل الصحفي
وتقييد انشطه الصحفيين والمواطنين
الصحفيين البلد يحتل اسوا المراتب في مؤشر
الصحافه العالميه لاسيما مع ازدياد عدد
الاعتقالات والاذانات التعسفيه وسجن
الصحفيين وايضا من حرمالهم من الرعايه
الطبيه جمعيه الصحفيين اعلنت ان الحكومه
والبرلمان يعتزمان المصادقه على هذه الخطه
والمشاريع ولكن سرا وذلك لعدم اتاحه اي
مجال امام ردود الفعل الرافضه طبعا وفقا
تعبير عنها
[موسيقى]
يا جوجو